[Music]  [Applause]  this is where we take videos of famous  people and we waste everyone's time by  combining them okay for no good reason  yeah first up we've melted Sir Elton  John and Vladimir Putin enjoy when you  have a big blowout have you pinched  peace changing depending the desks has  always been a constant because for me it  was my first on the bit record all right  this one John Kerry and Bashir al-assad  how can you prepare because I take it  easy the enough a doughnut cannot  recruit me the next picture  [Applause]  we alienate so many people so quickly  with this Mark Zuckerberg and Bert from  Sesame Street  what's he gonna do to me  and finally Larry King and the e-trade  baby doing it so long I thought I could  put the gum past me  [Music]  [Applause]  Larry looked like as a baby that's  caller